على كل حال سال الناس في السودان ما رايك
في هواس النساء بمنتجات التبييض نتابع
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
انا شايفه انه يعني ما في داعي انه نحن
نغير لوننا فالطبيعه دي قبل وحرفيا ما في
سبب مقنع بيخلي الواحد انه يغير لونه او
طبيعته العلو فهو ربنا اصلا لو كان عايزك
بشكل ثاني ما جابك بالشكل اللي انت فيه هو
فنحن نرضى به لونا وبيشكلنا مهما كان
وبالحاجه اللي احنا فيها ونتقبلها يعني
انا مع الكريمات لانه هي زي ماريا لكل
البنات جميل يحب الجمال احنا زمانك على
الطبيعه زي ما قلت الاخضر الاخضر والاحمر
الاحمر والاصفر والاسمر انا اسمراني
[موسيقى]
شكل الزول وانا شايف انه الطبيعه احلى
واجمل السودان شمسنا حاره وبتعمل على
اسمرار البشره فانا معها بس شنو ما يوصل
لمرحله الهوس انا اعتقد انه لو اهتمت
الانثى او اي من يبحث عن التبييض لو اهتم
بكماليات الروح وبالوعي وبالثقافه يمكن
انه يتقبلوا المجتمع زي ما تقبل المجتمع
كثير جدا من السمر